the rocky mountains provide a physical
divide between much of alberta and bc
now there's a new divide coveted 19
rules and it's become confusing we try
and do our best to ensure that people
know that
the vaccine mandate passports are still
in effect here it's as simple as this in
alberta proof of vaccination and masked
worn in indoor public places are no
longer required in british columbia both
still are and from fernwood to starwood
to the alberta border the difference is
being felt for those that enter that
don't
choose to be masked then
it
they don't force the issue because it's
not worth the confrontation
further north in dawson creek just 15
clicks from alberta the frustration the
same
this is not about the vaccine
per se anymore because i've got a
majority of the emails coming to me are
people who have been double vaccinated
possibly even triple vaccinated who are
saying i'm done
i need to know what's going on i want to
get back to my life and there's growing
concern from bc businesses that come
spring break dollars that typically
would be spent in bc will be spent in
alberta all because of the covet rules
with
spring break coming up are we going down
to edmonton to spend all our money and
go shopping or are we going to stay
locally in response to the concerns bc
health officials say the vaccine card
and the mask mandate have both been
successful and popular and their future
will be determined by public health and
not politicians
with great respect
i'm always interested
in what premier kenny
and premier mo have to say with respect
to public health orders in bc we listen
to dr henry that update is expected to
come on thursday where bc will become
the last province in the country to
outline when proof of vaccine and indoor
mask wearing will be phased out richard
zusman global news victoria